there's every indication that things
aren't good in Donald Trump's marriage
but I don't really care about that
what I do care about is whether Melania
Trump is being held sort of like a
hostage during the presidency remember
this incident from the inauguration we
did this story it got almost 4 million
views on YouTube where during the
inauguration Donald Trump turns to a
smiling Melania Trump says something and
then she seems absolutely miserable and
we wondered we speculated what did
Donald Trump say that crushed milania's
soul in this way it was absolutely
bizarre this new one I have for you is
probably even stranger Donald Trump
traveled all the way down to Fort Myers
Florida to do what I call hurricane
politics or whatever right show his face
after the hurricane he's in Fort Myers
he's standing between Mike Pence and
Melania Trump his wife right and he says
Melania really wanted to be here today
Melania really wanted to be here today
and of course Melania Trump is next to
Donald Trump let's take a first pass
through the video in the audio even
imagine and down here the same thing so
I want to thank everybody you guys I
don't want to see you next week or
another we've seen you enough but I just
want to thank everybody the first
responders on behalf of myself or vice
president Melania really wanted to be
with us he's really it's really touched
their hearts what's going on and we've
seen the devastation we're gonna see
some more of it now unfortunately now
when Donald Trump does this there's two
things to look at first is that Marco
Rubio over Trump's right shoulder looks
very very confused and then it's that
Melania Trump also initially doesn't
react but then does by looking off to
her left sort of strangely it appears
that someone was maybe patting her on
the back she appears emotionless Trump
appears emotion was speaking about her
and it's not clear whether Donald Trump
knows Melania Trump is next to him I'm
gonna play it for you just one more time
let's look at it together even imagine
and down here the same thing so I want
to thank everybody you guys have been I
don't want to see you next week on
another we've seen you enough but I just
want to thank everybody the first
responders on behalf of myself our vice
president Melania really
really really touched your heart flex
come on and we've seen the devastation
we're gonna see some more of it now
unfortunately look on Marco Rubio's face
is just priceless so what's the defense
here right I mean did Trump forget that
his wife is not only with him on the
trip but standing next to him after
traveling down to Florida from
Washington DC the defense is when Trump
said she really wanted to be here today
he met she is here because she wanted to
be her and she's very happy about being
here but it's a very strange way to talk
and it's also weird that if Trump is
aware that Melania Trump is right next
to him that when he says Melania Trump
really wanted to be here that he
wouldn't maybe look in her direction or
put his arm around her or signal to
Melania Trump it is downright bizarre
behavior it is a little strange because
he references Mike Pence and he kind of
makes a gesture to him correct but then
he references Melania and he doesn't do
the exact same thing and he uses very
different language to refer to one in
the other right but at the same time
it's not like he said Melania would have
liked to come here it's not conditional
tense in the same way and he's not he
wanted to come here and she is if you're
calling it a poor choice of words though
native speakers of American English
don't speak this way when they're
standing next to the person who really
would have liked a joint really wanted
to join us today and speculation is of
course rampant that Trump is
experiencing the early signs of dementia
that he had a moment of not recognizing
the person next to him that he just
didn't remember that he spent the
morning traveling on Air Force one with
Melania Trump and it's sort of it's just
very very strange and if you're just
writing it off as a linguistic incident
then I would be just as concerned why
can't a 71 year old man whose only
language the only language he's ever
spoken his English
why can't he speak in a more normal way
but remember Barack Obama gave a fist
bump to his wife Michelle some would
call that a terrorist fist but it was a
terrorist fist job yeah and that really
what we should be focusing on and if he
had done it while wearing a tan suit and
discussing a serious issue then that
could have been the end of his
presidency could've been impeachment we
are on Reddit at david pakman.com slash
reddit discuss this or any other stories
from the show that are important to you
there today's program I am pleased to
say is made possible by Casper
mattresses I've been sleeping on a
Casper mattress for just under two years
now when I moved to Boston
got a Casper mattress it shows up in a
box and you see the box and you say at
least I said there's no way that a
king-size mattress is in that box but it
was there and it is absolutely the best
mattress I've slept on they have
supportive memory foam and it creates a
sleep surface that has the right amount
of sink and the right amount of Bounce
and firmness and you can try it
risk-free for 100 nights if you don't
love it
Casper will pick it up and refund you
everything Casper understands the
importance of sleeping on a mattress
before you commit to it especially since
most people spend about a third of their
life on their mattress free shipping and
free returns to the US and Canada over
20,000 reviews and an average of 4.8 out
of 5 stars it's quickly becoming the
Internet's favorite mattress get $50
towards any mattress purchase by
visiting Casper dot-com slash Pakman and
using the offer code Pakman that's PA
que ma n Casper dot-com slash Pakman
offer code Packman save 50 bucks terms
and conditions apply